ouais enfin Madame je vais revenir
c'est une question importante parce que
tout simplement elle montre ou pas mais
en tout cas selon nous elle démontre que
le cabinet vous a questionné sur un
montant de subvention à cette
association l'US ppm avant même que tout
dossier soit déposé
aussi PDR donc il y a pas de dossier
déposé et votre cabinet vous interroge
sur un montant qui pourrait être affecté
à l'USPPM de 300.000 euros auquel vous
répondez
c'est votre mail c'est énorme ici mais
la demande en réel elle arrive après ce
qui tend tout simplement à dire que et
bien il y a eu une décision préalable de
votre cabinet de soutenir cette
association avant même de recevoir
quelques dossiers que ce soit et que
cette doux d'ailleurs le la demande qui
est faite aussi PDF et alors est-ce que
vous avez reçu le dossier mais parce
qu'ils ont déjà une position préétablie
de dire oui pour 300.000 euros en accord
avec vous alors un accord avec vous
sous la réserve que vous dites c'est
énormeissime et il vous répondent que
répondre techniquement que c'est jouable
que c'est il y a du que ça a du sens qui
était ce qui ne va pas et finalement ce
qui fait dire à l'IGA et c'est très
important que c'est des ni transparents
ni équitables c'est que des associations
ont finalement fait l'objet d'arbitrage
par votre cabinet
préalablement à toute demande et à tout
dépôt de dossiers et ça c'est
excusez-moi de vous le dire c'est votre
mail même que vous nous avez transmis
pour comment dire exprimer votre
position sur les 300 000 qui dit ça qui
dit que vous avez par arbitré mais était
questionné par votre cabinet sur 300.000
euros avant même
tout dossier ce qui veut dire tout
simplement que effectivement dès le
départ cette procédure fait qu'il y a
plusieurs types d'associations et qui a
des associés en particulier qui sont
réglés avant en tout cas pour celle là
les faits sont établis
est-ce que vous contestez c'est fait
moi monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur je n'ai d'abord dans les
mails c'est à vérifier mais il me semble
beaucoup de précaution mais il me semble
que le mail de mon conseiller ne fait
pas référence je crois au fond Marianne
mais qui fait référence
ne mélangez pas je vous ai donné une
matérialité une séquence je vous demande
juste est-ce que vous contestez les
éléments que je vous ai présenté
que la question est la question est
claire soit des versements qui ont été
fléchés par avance vous le dites et
ça clarifie les choses moi monsieur le
rapporteur je n'ai moi je suis comme
vous matérialité et chronologie et
matériellement je n'ai pas de fait qui
viennent dire que le cabinet donne un
ordre
de versement de cette subvention
d'abord le versement celui-ci PDF c'est
l'administration qui verse non il s'agit
c'est un pré fléchage sur un montant de
300000 qui d'ailleurs comme par hasard
devient finalement la proposition du
cpdr au moment du comité voilà c'est
tout simple je regarde monsieur le
Président ce que ce que ce dont je
dispose comme fait pour ces discussions
qui ont lieu il y a deux ans et donc je
me suis à ce dont je dispose ce dont je
dispose c'est qu'effectivement
manifestement les membres de mon cabinet
tout comme le cipdr était en soutien de
l'initiative portée par Monsieur cifaoui
leur mail démontre qu'ils ont un
enthousiasme vis-à-vis du projet de
Monsieur Sifaoui ça ne moi je n'ai pas
d'éléments qui vise à dire que le
cabinet aurait à ce moment-là arbitrer
ou décider quelque chose avant le comité
de sélection et je tiens à rappeler par
quelle porte d'entrée arrive monsieur
Sifaoui c'est par le SG c'est avec
lequel il travaillait ou l'entretenait
des relations précédemment
et l'autre le cabinet et le
cpdr travailler avec enthousiasme
c'était finalement que vous validez la
enthousiasme dans un même j'interprète
enthousiasme je n'ai pas d'éléments
matériels
que vous n'avez pas contesté la mère
terrialité des séquences ce qui
finalement est pour moi un élément de
réponse c'est un élément de réponse qui
nous permettra madame la ministre
ensuite de rendre nos conclusions voilà
je ne fais pas de je ne tire pas
d'enseignement particulier j'avais
simplement besoin au titre de la
Commission de vérifier le déroulement et
la chronologie des